people always told me that it hurts to
be loving this nothing we can do but
pray to God above I've heard a lot of
stories at all and sad but none that
I've heard sounds quite this bad it's
hard enough when love is unrequited but
what do you do when her boyfriend's dead
she was the first girl who ever made me
fall I just took too long to ask her to
the freakin you bomb hair like silk in
eyes a glow and she looks so pretty in
her schoolgirl robes and skin like
porcelain but she's a dead boy's
girlfriend she's a dead boy's girlfriend
I walk down that gilli Whedon jumped
into the lake not known who the Masters
of the tournament would take a dozen
burn people and the grim deal oh and
some pretty girls there pulling in a row
but it was babe Ronnie who was waiting
for me she was the prize purse educator
and she was the first girl who ever made
me fall I just took too long to ask you
- the three can you BA hair like silk in
eyes and Load robes and like porcelain
she's dead boy's girlfriend but she's
dead boy's girlfriend she's dead boy's
girlfriend
[Music]
on that fateful night Cedric and I we
finished that maze I'm the very same
time we grabbed the cup together to
share the glory I thought maybe he could
share something out with me but a minute
later he was dead and you could never
wanna be with me instead you could never
wanna be with me instead never wanna be
with me instead
we were the first girl who ever made me
fall just to do bot to ask you to the
freakin you live all hair like silk'n
eyes down and you look so pretty in your
schoolgirl robes and sin
and like porcelain
but she's dead boys go she's a dead
boy's girlfriend she's a dead boy's
girlfriend now it seems that all I made
you do is cry ain't never snarky when is
the secret why you still there between
us even though he's gone cheating on a
dead guy you should very wrong you
thought we have a very nice life but you
probably have to be a boring levels wife
you were the first girl who ever made me
fall I just took too long to ask you to
the freakin you'll fall hair like silk
in eyes and glow and love so pretty and
your school no robes and skin like
porcelain but she's a dead boy's
girlfriend yes she's dead boy's
girlfriend oh she's a dead boy's
girlfriend
[Music]
thank you all so much for my amazing
birthday wishes yesterday a final thanks
goes to the Catherine who wrote the
music to that song we make a pretty
great team I hope all of you even though
not Harry Potter nerd fighters in the
group enjoyed that song nerdfighters